do you worry about i know like minimum
wage increase and stuff like that do you
worry about that affecting businesses
like i
i hear stuff about like that do you
worry about that affecting small
businesses yeah i worry about
the people that just don't have enough
sales to support it and might not have
as sophisticated pricing strategies okay
so for me
you know quick service restaurants might
make between five and ten percent bottom
line
okay so everybody that comes in you're
doing good if you made five cents on a
dollar
ten ten cents on a dollar you're doing
great and so that means if somebody
spends a dollar you make 10 cents you
make
doing well you're usually five between
five cents and ten cents so
there's just not much margin there right
wow and between that five and ten cents
for every dollar spent there when you
have commodity pressures and things like
that which price of chicken goes up then
it just goes down
and so you just got slim margins that's
four before taxes that's five cents to
ten cents a dollar
before then you go get the taxes on so
if i spend ten dollars at a raising
cain's
right at uh what's the quick service you
talking about yeah quick service fast
food
okay so if i spend ten dollars at a
quick service restaurant
then if they're making ten cents of that
so if they're making a dollar out of ten
dollars that i spend then they're doing
well
doing well wow that's ten percent doing
well then that's before taxes right and
that's real numbers huh that's real
numbers and so when you think about it
we don't have margin to share right
because
um if labor prices go up
right and you got to do it you have to
pass it on to the customer there's no
way that you can supply because if it
goes below
five percent and gets lower you can't
lose money well and then you can't go
you're not gonna go put the
uh investment in to build and grow and
create more jobs and do it right so
the next location the roi is not there
and so you want you won't spend the
money and to the banks are gonna be like
hey you're not making return on
investment like we're not gonna continue
to lend you money
and so just the margins are that small
but so for me it doesn't
it doesn't hurt canes because you're
gonna eventually pass it on right
wages go up then you're gonna raise the
price of the chicken finger box right
it's just going to go
up and we have and you can't do that
overnight you have to stage into it
and so we're we just have a lot of
resources man i mean like i have a
strategy for pricing
the tough artists for small business
that don't think about that pricing
and then they don't want to do it the
next you know their their margins go too
small but
look it's going there 15 um an hour
minimum wage
we're going there i just i give advice
to small business i'm like
you have to pass it on and we're going
to go up but plan your pricing
strategies
ease into it and let your customers know
hey look just it's it's
labor prices and so it goes up so it
doesn't really concern me
it's a pricing strategies for small
business right because you have such a
broad
such a breadth of of information you can
pull in and you can look at it and you
can like
plan on a big scale but for someone
who's just kind of like made their menu
and it's very basic and they're not
thinking like oh well if the cost of
this goes up 50 cents
then i don't even make any money until
probably six months down the line when
they look at their books and like what
happened
what happened that's exactly what
happens and they don't these all these
small business owners they are so
reluctant to take price increases they
don't want their customers to pay i'm
like i know you have to or you're going
to be out of business
you know isn't that interesting about
that about that about sometimes about
people don't want to charge like i get
that way sometimes like i don't want to
make my tickets real expensive you know
i don't want to
even though sometimes i'll see other
people like holy smokes you know that
guy's tickets that price that's crazy
you know
but i'll get nervous about that i i
don't even know if it's nervous i don't
want to bother i don't want to
i don't know what it is i know i i think
i only take a crack at it
you start it from nothing and you
appreciate every fan
and it means something to you so it's
you take it personal right and so
you generally hold back same with small
business right they started from nothing
they've scratched they called and now
they have a a living and they don't want
to pass that on they're like i don't
want to do that to my customers i would
imagine you're probably the same way
yeah
and it's exact opposite in big corporate
america especially in restaurants
like those cfo types are like they
already have their pricing
it's not a personal decision it's all a
financial decision
that they're doing it's different for
people that that care
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one